New Hampshire votes tomorrow in the
first-in-the-nation primary it's likely
to be the last stand for some of the
Democratic candidates the CBS News
battleground tracker shows senator
Bernie Sanders leading the field he's
followed closely by former mayor Pete
Budaj edge and one week after the Iowa
caucuses the state's Democratic Party
party finally revealed mayor Budaj edge
won the most delegates with 14 to
Sanders 12 Ed O'Keefe is in Keene New
Hampshire for us at good morning are the
candidates changing their strategies
well good morning Tony they sure our
polls will be opening 24 hours from now
and they're attacking each other like
never before senator Sanders and Mayor
Buda judge especially going after each
other on policy and how they're raising
campaign cash while former Vice
President Joe Biden is making a
last-ditch attempt to save his campaign
the current frontrunner former mayor
Pete Buda judge and senator Bernie
Sanders blanketed the airwaves Sunday
and spent most of the day attacking each
other you know Pete has raised campaign
contributions from over 40 billion as
buddha' judge hit back by criticizing
Sanders his health care plan the plan so
expensive that senator Sanders himself
freely admits he has no idea how it's
supposed to be paid for our CBS News
poll shows Buda judge is now leading
among moderate Democrats in New
Hampshire
he's stealing support away from former
Vice President Joe Biden who was first
among moderates last month that explains
this Biden ad mocking the 38 year old
mayors small city experience when
park-goers called on Pete Buda judge he
installed decorative lights under
bridges Biden also called out Buddha
judges lack of support among black
voters we're gonna have to be able to
win a lot of places that in fact have
very diverse populations and so the
assertion that he's ready across the
board I'll see it the voters who know me
best in the african-american community
those in South Bend are backing me
another moderate senator Amy Klobuchar
is surging in late polls my staff told
me in the two days since the debate from
regular people online we raised over
three million dollars and then there's
senator Elizabeth Warren who's also
attacked who to judge and Biden in the
past and is now calling for unity look
we're gonna have to bring our party
together in order to beat Donald Trump
and the way we do this is not by
launching a bunch of attacks on each
other and trying to tear each other down
just like in Iowa Democratic primary
voters here remain undecided only 39%
say they've definitely made up their
mind and 37% tell us they would consider
somebody who's not even on the ballot
here former New York Mayor Mike
Bloomberg who of course is skipping the
first four early contests Hart state the
poll hard state to predict as well and
thank you very much